let's just undo it - shut up let's just
do it getting your butt into the chair
your hands on the keys stable right on a
schedule no matter whether or not
they've got needles sticking in their
eyes they'll just go ahead and sit down
and write my body my brain just goes
just right out it's right in there is
just right it wasn't that like them
we're wasting time right this grid that
script almost wrote itself like when I
think of like the the easiest writing
experiences that I think I probably
wrote that in five weeks of just getting
up and like you know hammering away in
it plumber nope doesn't a plumbers block
right teachers go to do their job it's
worth doing it's about doing your job
showing up at you that's your job you
have to understand that writing is a job
I was the editor-in-chief of my college
newspaper and there's a big sign in the
newspaper office underneath this huge
clock that had a like a blood-red second
hand and the sign said this is a daily
not a weekly and whenever we were there
past midnight the managing editor would
put up another sign that would say don't
get it right did it written
the first question always is what
want to accomplish and the second
question is am i succeeding at that if
you're not succeeding then you have to
change what you're doing if you're
committed to reaching the finish line
most people stay stuck in the real
question is what is the operational
phrase of your life for many people the
operational phase of their life is I'm
not getting what I want
well if that's the if that's the
sentence that's ruling your life you've
got to find another sentence and so it's
much more liberating if the sentence is
I'm going to get to the finish line and
I'm going to learn what I need to learn
I'm going to find what I need to find
I'm going to team up with whom I need to
team up with I'm going to create what I
need to create so that's liberating and
so from but also you should say let me
try something if it doesn't work I'll
try something else
a lot of people are very afraid of
failing and you know it's very funny
because you know Lane Lane will often
talk about well you know if you sell
down in real life would you just stay
down no you get up to continue on to
good stuff so but a lot of people feel
that if they fail that's the end of it
the doom will ensue and that's not what
happens and so and then it's another
thing that I've always find very funny
is when people say well life is like a
river and it'll take you where you're
meant to go and I always say to them if
you fell into a real river would you
have that opinion and if I can know
you'd swim like hell to get to the shore
life is not like a river life is
basically deciding what you want to
accomplish life is not it's very rarely
very rarely that you're handed something
on a plate what's like here this will be
easy
almost everything we try to do is hard
it's difficult but the more where women
say well I'm getting I'm going to get
where I'm going you know that's that's
what happens but it's more than what you
want to accomplish I think that there's
a very poisonous thing that we get
taught from time that we were small
which is that it's enough to not be
happy you know we don't think that if
you're not happy that it's enough your
happiness is something that we deserve
that we all deserve and to say that well
I'm living in ok life I don't think
that's ok he doesn't think that's ok
it's like no if you're not feeling happy
you're not feeling like you're doing
your best
I really believe that all of us were
born with gifts that belong to the world
and if we're too afraid to deliver them
well that's just a loss that's just sad
and I think a lot of it is linked to
actually enthusiasm and feeling happy
and giving that original piece that
we're all born with talent has to
understand even if it's not about how
many hours a day they invest on the
business side of their life it's more
deeper it's deeper than that
it's an understanding that I'm going to
well this into being I'm going to well
people into my life who are going to
help me I'm going to will new
relationships into my life I'm going to
take action that pays dividends it's not
ok to sit home and complain the glass
doesn't happen
do you ever ever ever ever you know
we're all well we're all allowed our
moment we're all allowed to have that
one day or that preferably that one hour
right then you have to dust yourself off
and say success is about moving on with
it and if other people aren't getting it
done for you then then you've got to
motivate them and the best way to
motivate someone is to show them what
they're not doing by doing it yourself
I think we've spent our life watching
and that we should continue to do so but
that's not really homework it's just
what we do and what we love and now we
don't have to feel guilty about it you
know great okay terrific
so you're doing that anyway as far as
networking goes it is the question of
keeping your eyes open shaking hands
making friends capitalizing on
relationships that that's all so that
can also happen at the same time this is
all sort of multi-platform stuff that
you're doing anyway so when it comes to
the real time spent for writing right
you know you can't really count any of
those things as well I was writing
because I was watching TV and I was
making a Fred you got it right
the biggest lesson about writing is get
up and do it you know is like it is a
job you know I I'm the kind of guy that
I like a glass of wine you know I like
some music going that's very romantic
and I'm sure Hemingway would be very
proud but like that's really not how you
get
script done or how you write that many
scripts and I I am always writing so
it's like you gotta get up you got to
spend time with your coffee you got to
look at it and sometimes it's just
sitting there not being able to write
anything that gets you two days later to
where you are where you can you know
answer the question and put it on paper
I know a lot of writers and these I'll
put in quotation marks who talked about
writing all the time who talked about
what they want to write and how much
they want to be a writer and how much
they want to be in a room and how much
but never make time for the writing
itself so to me those those are the
writers that will usually bring me a
comment to the conversation of do you
really want to write because you're
talking about it all the time when
you're not actually doing it and if you
are a writer who is not writing then
what are you in terms of this career you
have to have the discipline you have to
have the desire you have to have the
drives and you have to be willing to
make the sacrifices that most writers do
that it takes in order to become a
writer and that means waking up in the
morning early if you have a day job
sorry or writing on the weekends or
writing after hours rather than running
around partying with your friends
there's a lot of for most writers most
writers are not independently wealthy
right they're not going to be able to
sit around all day and take four hours a
day to write and then go party and then
go run around and then go travel the
world so most writers are going to find
themselves in a situation where they
have to have a day job potentially they
have a family they have a partner they
have friends they have relationships
they want to maintain and so writing is
going to demand some level of sacrifice
I had a writer that I'd worked with for
a number of years who we would meet
every three or four months and every
three or four months she would sit down
and tell me the list of excuses for why
she didn't write the previous three or
four months so the job was too hard and
she had to work out because she wasn't
healthy and she wasn't sleeping well and
she had to move apartments and she was
fostering dogs there was always
something and I truly believe that she
wanted she believed she wanted to be a
writer but at the end of the day if
you're not engaging in the thing right
whether it's right
or playing piano or any one of the
things you cannot claim this thing as
your own you have to engage in it in
some consistency and you know similarly
I meet writers who wrote a screenplay
ten years ago and haven't touched it
since but they're a writer but you have
to actively engage in the thing if you
want to be taken seriously as an owner
of the thing I don't friend of mine who
is the Dean of our School of Management
years ago said something to me is one of
those statements that you first hear it
you say that's kind of corny and then
you think about it say wow that's really
deep oh you said successful people or
people who know how to work when it's
hard and you know if I said hey why
don't you guys come over this weekend
we'll paint the room
get y'all pizza beer and that's like
grungy awful work is that hard is do
this a lot but when you're working on a
math problem and you can't solve it and
it makes your head hurt you want to give
up well you can't figure out how to
figure out fix act too and you just say
oh the hell with it successful people
are people who will hang in and solve it
as long as it takes and it's a rare
quality and people to do something when
they feel like maybe it's not going to
succeed it probably won't it's really
difficult it's making my head hurt and
still be able to stick to it under those
conditions
I couldn't improve that if I tried that
was great
hello one for me just for the hell of it
it's something simple
I got this rejection I know that I will
never be the person I want to be there's
usually a direct connection about what
rejection means about that person not
about the script or the person reading
the script I'm not going to make it as a
writer I will never be happy I will
never be fulfilled I'm just a loser I
didn't make it in this contest I can't
tell you the rhyme or reason of
screenwriting contests I've been in this
industry forever and I still don't
understand them and I have writers
saying I didn't make the quarterfinals
in the nickel on the loser I know that
I'm a loser now I'm a bad writer hold on
there's going to be a lot more
rejections there's going to be a lot
more opportunities to be a loser don't
jump at the chance so quickly but for a
lot of writers it's very real and done
me wrong every writer has a moment or 15
of being self defeatist you know I have
one writer who's a working writer who
always says that if you're not thinking
about quitting at least twice a week
you're doing something wrong and I
believe them I said I think it's very
very true I think every writer thinks
they're failing at a moment every writer
thinks that they're not good enough
every writer thinks that they're never
going to be able to recreate the past
success that they've had I think that's
perfectly part of the deal but seeing
everything as if failure as an
indication that you are just a loser you
are just a bad writer or you are just a
bad person that is what I see in the
more self defeated writers and the
problem is that nobody wants to work
with that nobody wants to be in a room
with that nobody wants to pick up your
script as a validation to who you are as
a human being I want to pick up your
script because it's a great script and I
want to bring it into the room because
they think you have something to
contribute not because they think that
you need the room I kind of know
anything that that can all change but
people get very scared of the middle but
for me that's when it gets fun because
it's so challenging and you so get too
what you know in the screenplay if you
think of a screenplay is 110 120 pages
you get the page 60 and you go oh my god
I'm only halfway there what happens next
but but something will happen and and I
and that's exhilarating and it's
exhilarating to go to bed completely
sure that you will never figure out
what's going to happen next and wake up
with the answer and then and and and
it's you know it's it's a it's it's a
daily challenge but it's a it's so it
feel it feels so good to realize that
that next scene will be there if you
keep working at it there's that there's
it's the best feeling in the world other
than finishing and then finishing it's
like the first draft no matter what
shape it's in it's like Napoleon I mean
that's just I always get tears in my
eyes when I finish a first draft because
I feel like I'm saying goodbye to a
group of people that I'd been on this
journey with and and and there's a
there's a very emotional side to it and
then you know then you become the
craftsman and time for a second draft
and all of that but it's it's an it's an
emotional journey and to do that day
after day it's it's incredibly rewarding
and I've got the best job in the world
now you're having a bad day this is not
one of the worst days of your life and
because of that you're going to keep
going and that's the truth of the matter
we're all going to have bad days here
and I'm here to support my writers
through them but it's about
understanding when there some bad days
and when it's all bad days it's very
easy to have an initial enthusiasm for a
creative project but it's very hard when
things start to become difficult when
you have to be there for the long haul
it's also particularly difficult if you
don't know if you're going to succeed so
often you're in the darkness and that's
where you need to surround yourself with
other people who have faith when you
falter years ago when I graduated from
UCLA as an art major by the time I got
out of UCLA knew I wanted to be
rather than visual artists even though
I've had art gallery shows of my work my
paintings in my photography one when I
was a teenager I knew I wanted to be a
writer I wanted to be a writer producer
in TV and there were no classes and how
to do that so I decided I would write a
book about the Twilight Zone TV show to
learn how to do that job so I started
writing The Twilight Zone companion and
we started submitting it as a project
publishers and for a two-year period it
was rejected it was rejected by 25
publishers and had it just been me I
would have given up but Elaine said keep
going keep going and we figured out what
why it wasn't selling he fired the agent
we had who had been Rod Serling's
literary agent and we got another agent
she submitted it back to one of the
publishers who rejected it to a
different editor and the book sold and
the book was an instant bestseller when
it came out it sold over half a million
copies and still in print all these
years later but if I hadn't had a lane
in my life who believed in me even when
I faltered the book I wouldn't finish
the book someone else would have come
out with a book on The Twilight Zone and
I would just spent the life rest of my
life and bars being dinner yes so so so
again we should have been a live DVD as
a drink yeah those really I would have
just believed those peanuts and drinking
like diet soda or something it would
have been really wasted life but again
it's very important to surround yourself
with people who love you and people who
believe in you and it's a two-way street
so a lane will falter and have that you
know dark days and I'll say no no let's
let's keep on this path so it's a
two-way street and that's really
important that cliche about working
every day whether you are inspired or
not it is so important I see it in
professional writers all the time even
if they literally are in agony as they
type and go this is this is crap
this is crap you never know what the
gold is going to be from that write it
whereas if you don't write it down if
you go you know what today is just too
tough it's too hard
I have no inspiration I'm not going to
write because I know when I write this
is crap those people fail almost all the
time because they don't ever write on a
discipline schedule so they're never
they don't have crap that they can go
back in and go oh look here's a gold
nugget oh here's another gold nugget I
guarantee you if you
right five pages of what you think is
utter crap that within that you'll find
a paragraph if you give yourself enough
Zahn
that will literally propel you another
chapter or two or another scene or two
and that's what that's sort of a secret
of a professional writer that really
distinguishes him from an amateur writer
is that they will write on a schedule no
matter whether or not they've got
needles sticking in their eyes they'll
just go ahead and sit down and write I
would just say working in you know
studio system for ten years or whatever
toughen you up to the point where you
just you have to be prepared for all
sorts of scenarios often especially as a
writer rejection so at this point you
know it's still you could still on your
mind and you're still hoping and I feel
like we you know we thought we were
making something you know really
interesting great and so you know
probably a little bit confident in my
better moments and I'm sure I had some
some some darker moments that late at
night so um but but everybody was so
enthused and you know having such a
great cast having a guy like Reece
behind the camera you know definitely
instill the confidence in us but but
sometimes it's hard to come by in this
business can you get knocked down so
much and things just usually don't turn
out as you planned as much as you try to
to you know harness control of your work
it can it can go sideways at any moment
I had a friend who was an aspiring
writer and he had final draft so I went
to him and I said hey man I want to
write a script and he was like you wanna
what I said just give me a final draft
show me how it works
he's like doesn't know how final draft
lawrence welk dude whatever just you
know I just show me how it works so he
taught me how it works I could just do
that and hit the tab key
right things like alright what are you
gonna write oh its own right script
right script we didn't have an idea not
it's like I'm floating around now no so
I can just know right one I read them
all my life can't be that hard hard I
just figured write script start like
what am i doing I'm sitting here and
staring at a phone doesn't ring
you know folks not going anywhere I'm
not going anywhere I could be sitting
here a year from now and me and my phone
can be hanging out together or I can be
sitting here here from now me and my
phone could be hanging out with a script
that I wrote so I started writing every
time I walk into the class the first
evening all our classes are evening
evening classes and in the new class the
first year people there for the first
semester and I walk in and they're
chattering away and trying to get to
know each other and so forth but they
haven't you know really had any anything
to do with me and I walk in it was
always weird and creepy because as soon
as I walk in deathly silence falls
everybody's waiting so I look very
austere and serious and I walk to the
whiteboard and I write on the whiteboard
and very very large letters write badly
with pride and then they laugh you know
everybody everybody laughs and it cuts
the ice and you know it works that way
and I turn around and I smile and I say
yes but I'm not kidding for it is a
critical importance for writers to
permanently give themselves permission
to write badly if writer's block is all
about expecting and demanding oneself
perfection anything any word any
sentence it's gotta be great it's got to
be great
no that way lies right early death you
do that you'll end up freezing so solid
you'll never write again it is exactly
the opposite writing is a craft it's a
crap
and how do you how do you participate in
the craft it's a craft that it's you
that exercise with words and it is like
in I don't know statuary or something
you start out with a big gooey pile of
wet clay and you started mush it you get
your hands dirty you know you get down
in the mud and you're mush it and squish
it then you start making choices of a as
you shape it the pieces you're not going
to need and so forth and you go from
there but you start out with mess that's
what we do as writers we start with mess
and then we make choices first hundreds
of choices and then thousands of choices
and before we're done tens of thousands
of individual choices have been made but
you cannot make choices and you cannot
see what or choose what direction you
want your story to go in or have you
wanted to develop unless you have a pile
of words on the page so we have
exercises sometimes just let's try it
let's write as badly as we know how and
it's funny you read them aloud everybody
gets a laugh it's kind of that and what
they find out is even when they are
trying to write badly because that's
what we're doing it's this little
exercise it still comes out funny it's
still it's it's not bad in other words
they're they're funny they're cute
they're weird they're quippy but even
writing badly they're not really writing
that badly at all I know writers
directors and put themselves on that
pedestal because they've had this degree
of success and they feel that they have
to come in and be very buttoned down and
very above the people that they're
talking to or talking down to I don't
look at it like that at all I will tell
you about my bad night my hangover my
whatever but but and part of it again
it's like free therapy but part of it is
also this is this is my life and we're
and sometimes it's not terribly
respectable but I'm responsible because
I'm responsible because I will get my
ass to my computer and right and don't
worry about being perfect but that is a
dead that I wish I could say that that
my success rate was a hundred percent
with that but again most people will
never finish their scripts because that
sense of needing to be perfect oh I'm
being boring oh this isn't gonna this
isn't working it will take over and it
will crush their creativity and it's a
very sad thing the witness I try to get
people over it I try to say look it's a
first draft I tell you no don't worry so
much but but that is the toughest job
any person who's teaching any kind of
creativity has is to convince people to
get out of their own way and my way of
doing it again is to say today students
I am a hot mess but I wrote but I but I
wrote for four hours and then they feel
okay that they're also imperfect but
whatever sort of front were all we know
we all have our public image that we put
out there I think that's great because
it's really well they feel superior to
be yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean yeah but
I'm not it but again it's some of it
it's just the nature of my personality
but but some of it's very deliberate I
just don't you know I I you know i I've
knock wicker I've made a living at this
for thirty years I mean it's insane
sometimes great sometimes so skating by
sometimes whatever but it hasn't come
out of being perfect believe me but it's
coming out of having enough discipline
to write screenwriting is quite often
times very challenging
very difficult on a daily basis so you
have these waves of these peaks of
megalomania where you write 20 pages in
the day and you think you're an
incredible writer and you think you're
unstoppable and then you have these
other days where or weeks where you
don't write a word or you don't write a
page or you don't get anything done and
you really reach these valleys of
self-loathing so I don't feel like
there's really an in-between there's no
real middle ground I think you are
mainly in the trenches most of the time
you are dealing with self-doubt in my
opinion as a writer and dealing with the
hardships that come along with trying to
create whether it's a feature film or a
novel or a television pilot or project
so I think sure maybe some writers out
there optimistic about their ideas and
and what the story they want to tell but
I think the overall psychology and
mentality of a writer from my opinion
and from my experience is is that of
someone who is constantly dealing with
challenges on a daily basis and so for
me I don't know that I would say I'm
optimistic I'm very excited about what
I'm writing most of the time but that's
on the surface of things I think when
you dig deeper you know we are self
loathing individuals you know we have we
have issues with self deprecation and I
think for me that's that's usually where
I'm at
when you're in my class you know I'm
always like leave the drama on the page
you know I want to hear about it let's
get writing you know that's sort of how
how I work and I always feel like sort
of the the writing pushes through the
issues or you can take those issues and
given to a character this can be really
cathartic for you but as far as people
being attracted to failure maybe one
kind of writer is I don't know if all
writers are I think some people are just
attracted to storytelling it begins with
the excitement of an idea you know Vince
Gilligan said you know when he started
Breaking Bad it was just the idea he was
sitting around with a friend of his and
they were bemoaning the fact that they
weren't working and he just goes man you
know maybe we should cook meth and it's
been laughs ha ha ha and then from that
he had the idea Wow cooking meth what
would that be like so the whole story
came from this little nugget this little
excitement and I see that all the time
with writers is whatever excites you is
the place to start in your story one
deadly thing to do is to go ok well hmm
what's selling let me go to The
Hollywood Reporter and see what's
selling right now okay well is not
selling action selling all right I'll
write an action movie that is almost
guaranteed to leave you uninspired
Beetlejuice for instance the idea was
that I discussed with my partners a
psychedelic ghost comedy we had no idea
what that meant but it rolled off the
tongue right and and and and I usually
have something of an idea like that and
I kind of know the beginning and I kind
of know the end the middle is the great
unknown but but but but it's it's an
instinct an idea and sometimes it's a
character and sometimes it's a situation
but it's very it's very internal at
first and and and yes there's times
where you write an assignment you know
and you
you're you're given an idea and say
translate this into a movie but in terms
of my my own my own writing if you will
my my personal writing it usually comes
from front from just the most basic kind
of idea and a feeling you know and and
it's like and I can't articulate it very
well I'm sorry because it's hard to
articulate but it's just kind of like
again like a situation in our character
that's just kind of waiting to come out
and then you whatever you whatever your
process is and boy do you need a process
and boy do you need to go to work and
boy do you need to sit down and do it
and do the job of writing and and and
you allow that that character of that
situation to just start growing and
start coming you know leaving your
fingers on to the digital page these
days you know on your computer and then
it grows and expands and it takes on
life and and you know I there's of
course and this is that this is every
writers choice there's a lot of talk
about backstory always you know like
like tell it you know where did your
character go to school how you know what
was his or her mommy like and all of
that I've never written a back story in
my life never but if you ask me to tell
me the back story one of my characters I
could I'd kind of be making it up as I
went along but the feelings would be
true because I feel I I feel the
characters and I and I feel like they
need to come out and I feel like they
need to be given a voice and and that's
just that that that's that's what
writing is to me a an idea or a
character or situation or mo
or a feeling that you somehow have to
put into the world and it's hard to
articulate and I feel like I'm talking
in circles but I but it's it just it's
almost hard not to because it's so it's
so in ephemeral in the beginning the
same thing that happened with Carroll
has happened with all subsequent
projects
I read the novel obsessively maybe four
or five six times just quickly make a
bunch of notes that I then never ever
refer to ever again I just write things
down it's a bit like rote memorization
maybe that you you you take this stuff
in maybe by osmosis and then I go away
and I do something else so I'll go to a
bunch of baseball games our own you know
watch TV or all have to go to Vegas
something for a few weeks and then I
come back and if I've got say ten weeks
to do something I'll use eight of them
in other ways I won't even think about
it and then I'll sit down and I'll write
from page one to the end very quickly
and without stopping without revising
and without shuffling scenes around
there's something about a structure for
me
arriving at how something begins and
ends provides a structural tool and
that's really the way music mostly is
composed so I look at it that way and
then the revision is always the same if
something is wrong on page 46 you know
the previous 45 pages also have to be
adjusted and all the pages that follow
because one thing is off it's set
something off in another section I've
never been someone who's learned how to
do that thing that I always see with
famous screenwriters you
the cards the the ability to take one
scene here and put it here and it always
seems that's not my process it's got to
all work as a piece in one long act
almost I think that Alex probably is
more like let's just do it to shut up
let's just do it and I like to um you
know really challenge every idea and
make sure we're you know taking the
right path but it's a great mix because
it sort of keeps each other on our toes
you know I think that one more just like
to right away and the other maybe let's
just think about it for a second it's a
good push-pull probably spending about
90 percent of the time writing in the
same room we feel like it keeps us we're
moving ahead and also we talk through
everything first so we never really sit
down without knowing what the other ones
doing and then we'll usually will either
break stuff up or one of them will take
the one of us will take the first step
and then the other will come in and just
start rewriting it right away we
generally like to write what we call a
vomit draft just to try to get kids
something out on paper right away and
that can sometimes be very close to what
ends up and sometimes it can be entirely
different but um it's it's important to
just start getting your thoughts out on
paper but yeah it's it's um it's it we
pretty much split up a lot of the duties
and sometimes you just find this little
germ of an idea you know and it can just
be you know a single thought or a little
you know some little thing you know or a
parson or whatever and one little thing
and then it stops to just like pull
things together you know you start to
see the resonances of different things I
really love that approach to writing a
screenplay you know that it's really
it's an act of curiosity and discovery I
feel like when you write a screenplay
it's like being an archaeologist you're
excavating something that already exists
somehow and I think that sort of organic
path for me is definitely
the way the Bears the most fruit when I
tried to be clever or try to do it in a
more strategic way I think the results
are less interesting I mean I do have a
thing when I'm writing a first draft
where I generally say I write four to
five pages a day one side
once I start to write the script you
know like four I'll let myself have
months of just like cooling things
together you'll know and I'm always
buying books that are connected to
whatever it is in watching films you
know just like just filling up all the
well in a sense and then I reach a
certain point where I'm like I'm ready
to write the script you know and and
then I'm totally strict about just you
know I'll set myself like four pages a
day or 5p Tuesday and that is it like
there's no excuse you know if it takes
you all day trips all day if it takes an
hour it takes an hour but that's the
minimum you're going to write every day
then I get the script done that way and
you know I think like when you're in
that puzzle like somewhere usually
before you actually start writing a
script she's just not like it just if
it's if it's not that interesting to you
the resonances on it if you're having to
force it you know at this stage then I
feel like abandon it a JumpShip know
because it's that stage of gestation and
leading up to writing your first draft
if it's not holding you then it's it's
not gonna hold you you know and maybe
it'll come to you later you know I have
had that experience I think actually my
second film is is it was a little like
that because I think it had the idea
person I've had it for years percolating
you know the idea of a yoga teacher and
a sex worker in this relationship
between them you know and so something
but I couldn't really find it I couldn't
really crack it before and then suddenly
it was like oh yeah I get it they're
sisters you know and different things
you know came into that so you know I
think sometimes if you do have a good
idea but it's not quite working out
you're having to force it and you're
pushing through it you know sometimes
the best thing is to leave it set aside
working something else and then maybe
it's a year later two years later three
years later you come back ten you go now
I know what that needs you know and and
it can go again this is going to sound
terrible um there are things you're
supposed to do as a writer that you
should do you should make outlines make
your character breakdowns all these
things that you like do and make your
cards you plot out your story or first
and second third I'll do any
none of it that's the perfect
screenwriter
yes woman has the folded sock drawer yes
that's the guy does it all correctly out
with it I like to sit and think about
the idea and then I like to think about
the character who that woman or man is
and what they're like and what their
world looks like and then I just start
to think about what the movie might look
like in my head and once I sort of start
seeing the movie itself in my head then
I start writing I don't know how it's
going to end necessarily unless it's a
thriller if it's a thriller I need to
know how it's going to end so I can know
where I gotta go if that makes sense
you know because you always want to have
that ending that can go home so you
think of the ending first like what
would be a cool hole and then okay now
how do I get there so I go backward if
it's a thriller if it's not a thriller
if it's just a story about people in
life in love or whatever it is then I
don't really think that much about
what's going to happen I just sort of
think about the people and where they
are and where I want them to be what the
world's like what they enjoy there's
usually a lot of wine involved because I
enjoy some wine and what happens is I
end up writing something that's more
organic and spontaneous because I
haven't sort of telegraphed it and kind
of like it when you're acting you know
you always hear don't play result you
know you've read the entire script so
your character is on a journey so you
know what that journey is but the
character doesn't know so you don't want
to play like you know what's coming
because you'll Telegraph it to the
audience I find the same thing works for
me as a writer by not knowing everything
when I'm writing I'm discovering and as
I'm writing and it makes the writing
process exciting for me because I'm like
sitting there at the keyboard I'm like
this is great
you know like what's going to happen
next I don't know I can't wait find out
either you know what I mean it's like
it's a spontaneous thing
and then hopefully the training and laws
of inevitability that I try to keep
focused in my head you know kick in as
I'm writing and when it's done it's it's
a really great it's a really great story
but yeah I I like to look at it as a
living breathing story that's unfolding
as if I'm watching it and that drives me
toward the end because I feel like if I
do all the outline stuff for me if I do
all the outline stuff I've already kind
of done it already
so now I was like oh not gonna write at
all
I dunno I already figured it out so I
just like jump in start writing and when
I'm inspired literally it just all comes
out so like even my first screenplay I
thought about it for two or three months
and then literally I wrote it in like
three weeks so when that happens when
I'm inspired like that and I've been
literally thinking about a project and
sort of letting it marinate it just all
comes out so I say everybody has a
different process but I would probably
have a lot more product if I just
committed to write something every day
it could be a poem it could be anything
I think that's just really wonderful to
do but I have so many different
interests that writing is one of them
come on an idea I get excited about it I
tend to write it very quickly I used to
do outlines
I don't do outlines anymore because
unless unless it's very complicated
because I'll start writing the outline
and I think it's so much detail off in
the beginning that I'm often trying to
write it fast up before I forget what
I'm thinking so if I start writing an
outline by page two it's becoming scenes
anyway like I keep like it's like see
what I mean about one world it's gonna
write one sentence pretty Nancy wants
this and he do is this insane trees this
scene for is this and see I know I'm a
driving scene so I just start running to
the script and I tend I try to write
very quickly the first time I try to
write 10 pages a day trying to think
about it too much just puke it out just
back I also don't often write an order
so I try to write where I'm excited to
write
this Gina - cloud - that and then write
this and then write this and I cut up
again I kind of already know how it's
all going to go together and when I'm
done I have a you know a first draft you
know less than two weeks then I step
away from it for a couple of weeks and
go back and look at it really if I'm
honest I'm always figuring it out as as
I write even if I go in thinking that I
know what it is I'm still going to end
up figuring it out as I go
yeah this is I have inside out writing
and outside in writing and the outside
in will tend to be something where
there's kind of an external story and
then so you're kind of you've got the
container a little bit and then you're
figuring out all of the ways that you're
furnishing and arranging what's in that
container and generating some new stuff
but and then when occasionally I I have
the luxury of doing kind of what I call
the inside-out where you just you have
almost nothing you have like you woke up
in the middle of the night with like an
image in your head or you know you're
just kind of just very fragment carry
thing like a grain of sand and then it's
like you're making stone narrative Stone
Soup you're like here's the pebble and
then you know do you know the story of
stone stone through they go around they
get the meat and the carrots and and
everything and then it's more like it's
like found art like just pulling all of
the the things from your life your
memories and what's going on and and
you're kind of building it out from from
this little thing and it becomes
something where you really didn't have
much of an idea what it was going to be
at all and so that's that's pretty fun
and and that would again of course be an
example of figuring it out and here as
you go it's just throwing ideas around
at first and CRISPR gosh who co-wrote
starlit and tangerine he's wonderful at
note-taking so he's there typing away
just compiling every note possible into
something I don't know even know what
he's typing what made a simple text or
something is just compiling all these
notes so the first day is really just us
brainstorming spitballing ideas there's
a point where there are enough notes
down on page and you you understand your
story enough where it's time to start
writing those pages so I might write a
page he'll write a page we'll start
sharing them I know that we used both
films I think we used Google Drive and
we were sharing a lot that way you know
we also go about it
where we eventually get to a point where
we we have the post-its on the wall and
that that that's when you when you
actually can get a film where your idea
your you know your script up on the wall
and like with hundreds of post-its and
it makes sense from beginning to end I
think that's when we decide to start a
signage other pages and scenes so we'll
say okay you look at that scene I think
I got a handle on that saying I'll take
that can you take that one because I
don't have a handle on that one and then
we share them and then we start to
compile this thing and that's how that's
that's how that's done I focus more on
the last scene and the impact the last
team will have that's almost one of the
first things I think about the endings
are very important to me because it's
about how the audience leaves the
theaters you know I I think very much so
about the impact of that last scene if
you think I look at my favorite films
and my favorite films are like Harold
and Maude and when he's walking away at
the end after you know the the car goes
over the cliff and you think he might be
in it but then he's up on the cliff and
he's with his banjo you have some most
of my favorite films have such
incredibly memorable lasting scenes that
have an impact on the audience as
they're sitting there during the final
credits and I think that that's
something I'm always conscious out of
it's it's the most important thing for
me in a screenplay the process of just
starting to write is so challenging that
I often come up with the title first
it's so backwards like I don't know any
screenwriter who they're like like
literally I've written a whole
screenplay from a title that inspired me
there's a title of the big empty a
friend of mine had a song called the big
empty and I was like that's a great
title for script the big empty so I
literally wrote the biggest day and
thought okay what's it going to be about
and then I kid what was all script for
what this was going to be about so I
think it's just getting started I'm not
someone who does even even though my
very first successful screenplay was
almost like doing an outline it was like
a stream of consciousness treatment that
I wrote and then I realized after
writing like 20 or 30 pages you should
just write the scripture it's right here
you should just write the script but
that's because I have been marinating on
it for so long I could just do that
but when it comes to outlines which is a
process that a lot of script writers do
and I'm still trying to figure out how
to do that I really admire people who
really know how to outline and write
their scripts from there things are just
a little bit more organic for me but I
can write like a beginning a middle and
an end but it's usually about two or
three pages of stuff and a character
breakdown so we're all a bunch of humans
running around okay and on some level we
are all pretty much the same right
biologically whatever however what
really separates us is our experiences
and our perspectives because everyone
although similar you know American
culture is similar let's say we're
growing up in a city or growing up in
the suburbs or you know these kinds of
things what you've experienced through
your life and what you're interested in
and what you're educated in and things
like that that is what really gives you
your voice
right so if you can tap in to what
matters to you and understand why it
matters to you then you can write with
power not only from your head and your
imagination but from your heart if what
you're writing doesn't matter to you
it's going to be flat it's never really
going to in mode but if you can tap in
and understand what your gifts are what
your perspective is what you believe
then you can create characters and
stories based around that fictionalize
it you know embellish it or whatever
however you do it dramatize it and then
create within a narrative structure you
know as a screenplay and that is what
great screenplays come from first you
should appreciate the value of
daydreaming daydreaming without a
purpose is an imagining other world
actually does scientifically stimulate
your brain and relax you
physical exercise always important
taking a walk around the building
getting your body moving getting your
endorphins moving some people actually
need really heavy endorphin push to get
out of that hamster brain and into into
a meditative space for a lot of people
meditations really hard because you let
your worried mind take over so finding a
simple exercise like watch literally
thank to your breath it's yourself in in
in breath out out out breath and and and
allowing just your own voices in in in
out out out can calm you down but the
other thing is belief when you believe
that you have to get somewhere or you
have to achieve something it's much
harder to get there if you believe that
who you are right now what you're
writing right now is actually destined
to come in the world
old and you can just relax and let it
come and the thing that you're going to
write next is the perfect sentence and
the next word is the perfect sentence
and even if you're just writing I don't
know what I'm writing I don't know what
I'm writing I'm waiting for something
inspiring to come to me I'll just wait
and keep typing and then you start
enjoying the feeling of typing start
enjoying the feeling of your fingers
start enjoying a great word pick a
surprising word and I promise you
eventually if you just keep typing that
next idea will come and the next idea
will come and if you don't judge it you
allow the next thing to come there will
be a progression that will take you
forward but I love working on all
different genres like that's what's
always fun to me is getting hired to do
you know like a punch-up on a kids movie
or here's a horror film or you know
here's a family drama but like I love
getting to do all of them because I love
movies and it's it gets boring doing the
same thing over and over again so as far
as like what taught me the most I think
it was just it's just being thrown to
random here I need you to do this
suspense action film for me you know and
like sometimes you'll get a finished
script and you'll fix it sometimes
you'll get a paragraph and you'll
execute it you know it's like so yeah I
don't know all of them I guess it's just
the the process of writing you just get
better at it and like that's something I
tell young people all the time is like
you get practing the more you write so
you have to write you know I mean all
the time
we definitely live in a culture
especially in the screenwriting world
where you're supposed to read as many
scripts as you can to learn how to write
write read read read read read but I
believe strongly in bubbles I believe
you should put a big magic thick plexi
silent bubble around you when you write
so they and and and the other thing you
put in your bubble is everything that
you love if you love you know bubblegum
and butterflies and unicorns or if you
love you know you know 60s music or
whatever it is you have to surround
yourself with the essence of you and and
and be careful of criticism I'm a strong
believer in not allowing any of the baby
the babies that you're writing to ever
see the light of day I've seen so many
babies who've just been born as little
scripts be told that they will never get
go to college and never grow up to be
beautiful because someone didn't get
them and you think about projects now
like transcendence and me sorry it's
like a projects like transparent and
quirky stories orange is the new black
or where they're deeply personal and
they would never show them they never
live if the wrong person saw that story
and so be careful and be careful of
allowing criticism the careful of
allowing other voices surround yourself
with the bubble that is authentically
you so you feel yourself you taste
yourself you smell yourself and you love
that bubble and what comes out of that
will be so much more unique and in this
world of storytelling uniqueness
authentic authenticity originality is
what it breaks through and so that's
what you want you want to take a big
bath and you it's not that cliche write
what you know
because I've never written what I quote
unquote know I write fantastical worlds
and and and and and supernatural stories
and all of that but write what you feel
and write what's in your heart and write
something that means something to you
and you know I was a script reader for
God probably a decade and I and the and
and I was reading seven eight scripts a
week and the rare one was the great
script and when you found that that was
a very exciting day at the office
and sometimes the really terrible
scripts were kind of they were fun
because they were so god-awful but the
ones that got really exhausting and
really enervating as a script reader
who's sitting there and asked to read a
script synopsize it write a comment
about it and pick up another one and
read it and it's not were the ones that
you could tell were written by people
who were looking at what last year's hit
was and trying to imitate it and those
were deadly and they were they weren't
good they weren't bad they were safe and
mediocre and any writer any young writer
any old writer anyone who's just
starting to write anything write
something that you feel write write
write write something that comes from
the heart and and and people may not
think of Betelgeuse is a personal movie
it's an intensely personal movie it was
intensely personal for Michael me and
and you know I I didn't know I had a
theme until I had enough work to realize
I had a theme and almost everything I've
written are about broken families who
are put back together in some bizarre
way but there but but because I came
from a broken family and and what and
and so so the there's a I like
think that my work has a sense of heart
in a sense of compassion and a sense of
humanity in it no matter how bizarre it
is no matter how weird the worlds get
and and you got you got to write
something that you feel on something
that you have some passion for or just
why do it it's too hard it's just it's
not an easy job and and I personally
can't imagine saying well this was a hit
now so I'm going to I'm going to write
my version that I don't really it's not
really what I care about what I feel but
I can imitate it well enough I can't
imagine spending a year of your life
doing that but people do it all the time
and they usually write me do Chris Krebs
I think people chase trends you know oh
I don't know romantic comedies are big
this year let's bright romantic comedies
okay like is that really coming from
what you're passionate about maybe but
maybe not
often I also think screenwriters don't
dig in deep enough to really understand
where they're coming from the pain and
the and the triumphs that drives these
stories so continually digging deeper
asking yourself why are you doing this
why do you care about these characters
so by digging into these kinds of
questions these kinds of truths these
kinds of subjects a screenwriter can get
a lot deeper into what they believe and
then express it but I guess I'm just
suggesting that as you're considering
what to write these kinds of questions
can really inform and activate and
engage your stories and your characters
if they matter to you they will matter
to somebody else and if they don't I
just want as a screenwriter I often see
this kind of advice to screenwriters
which goes something like you know read
the trades and and see what's selling
you know and then write something like
that and study other screenplays and I
think good god you know I mean I think
reading a lot of books is very important
I think reading watching tons of movies
is super important reading some
screenplay see understand the format in
the craft but then like allowing
yourself the space to really go off the
reservation you know and just allowing
it to form in its own way because the
first draft is really I mean it's just
the start of a very long journey you're
going to rewrite your script at least 20
times before you shoot you know I don't
I've never heard of anyone that does
less than probably 20 drafts from a
first script shooting script you know if
they do I'd love to meet them but I
think most people it's like it's you
know it's a process you know and your
first draft you just want to make
yourself as free as you can and as
honest as you can and as curious as you
can and let things unfold and that will
I think that gives you the best chance
of writing something that's going to be
you know engaging and unique we all want
to be successful and one of the ways we
we find success and is to look at other
people and say oh I can pick I can I
like the way she looks so I'm going to
look like her I like the way he writes
so I'm going to write like her and you
hear all these stories is like even Joan
Didion who copied Ernest Hemingway in
order to find her voice but what you
want to do but you know you're on the
wrong track if you if you start feeling
that anxiety that I could never be like
her but I'm oh when I compared myself to
his writing just really not I and you
start feeling that that sense of not
good enough not needing something and
you start wanting to be seen you can
feel that pull of wanting to be seen
like your Idol right and and that's the
moment where you know if you were
talking about a physical look you'd go
get plastic surgery right so I could put
her nose on my face so I can put his
words in my script on my story and so
when you start feeling that you have to
recognize that you're walking away from
yourself
you're walking away from yourself and
trying to sit in somebody else's image
and if you do that you will always be a
shadow of someone else the truth of who
you are the reason that you came to
write won't come out won't flourish it's
kind of like you'll you'll be that that
that plant that just doesn't get enough
water and doesn't get enough Sun so it
might bloom but the flower will be small
and the fruit will be bitter right and
if you're really going to anchor in
yourself you have to believe that you
are as brilliant as as the person you
want to be and so you're going to
appreciate how they shine but you're not
going to copy how they shine you want to
appreciate how strong they are in their
voice and you want to practice your own
voice as loudly as you can
now the awkward thing is you're going to
practice that voice and it's not going
to be good right we're never good when
we start playing the piano
we'll never great when we start driving
we crash into things right it takes
practice but you have to hang on to the
belief so this is the disconnect you
have to know that even though you may
not look good at what you're doing what
you're doing is not accomplishing the
vision of what you want to accomplish
ultimately you have to believe that
you're going to get there just as you
are
so it's hanging on to the tension of
being not so good an amateur
awkward but believing that you're going
to grow into something that will
flourish and bloom and you're going to
have to have patience and that's the
most difficult thing because when you're
when you're struggling and you want
success and you know you're good but
it's not coming there's a tendency to
say what I'm on the wrong path the
universe doesn't want me to do this I
should go to that path I should follow
that path
anger in this is where meditation
becomes really important and really
knowing that there's a there are stories
inside of you that need to be told just
the way you want to tell them and having
the patience to wait for them to bloom
so that the timing is right and that
your timing is right as an artist and
that timing is rising the marketplace
you have to write on a schedule I've
never known a writer who didn't write on
a schedule who succeeded who just said
I'm just going to let inspiration carry
me where it will I've never seen a
writer succeed doing it that way I'm not
saying you couldn't I've just never seen
it every writer I know there succeeds
has a discipline about them one of the
things that I teach writers from the
very beginning non writers who are
starting out and then the what and a lot
of them won't do this but the ones that
do not only do they become better
writers this will save their rear ends
when they have a career is I teach them
the idea of a writer schedule so what
that means is if you have a job that
pays the bills in Thursday at 3 o'clock
you have to do a marketing proposal to
your boss I know where you're going to
be Thursday at 3 o'clock you're going to
be doing that proposal if you don't feel
like it and you don't like to Fogle's
that good you're still going to do the
best you can if you feel like watching
TV or napping you're going to be there
or you're not going to have a job and
you know from 10 a.m. to 12 p.m. you are
supposed to meet with this client you're
going to do that and you schedule your
life around that so what I tell people
is no one is going to treat you like a
professional until you are a
professional no one's going to invest
money in you until you put the money
where your mouth is so you have a career
perhaps you have a family perhaps you
have all of these poles on your time I
get that every Sunday night you're going
to create a writer schedule for the next
week and maybe you could only write 45
minutes a day ideally an hour or two
hours let's say 90 minutes a day you
will block out that writing time be it
at 7:30 in the morning be at 6 o'clock
whatever it is for every day for that
week now if you've blocked out Thursday
from 7:30 to 8:30 is your writing time I
know we're going to be at 7:30 you're
going to be writing and if not if you
feel like it because that's like your
marketing meeting with your boss so you
schedule out your writing time every
single week and then you honor that and
if you're not willing to do that and
you're not willing to honor that why
should anyone else
that's money in you I found and this is
still true for me that I work best in
the morning and so I would get up and
kind of a lot of times what helps me is
to exercise and if I'm you know either
jogging in those days or now on an
elliptical machine in the in the gym
that time and taking a shower and stuff
is really productive for me to think
about what I'm going to be doing that
day with my writing or to solve a
writing problem I'm having so that when
I hit the desk so to speak I'm really
hit it running and I've got some
momentum and that that worked for me I
also think I just enjoyed writing I
really wanted to achieve this goal
really badly and and could see that
others were achieving that it wasn't
like yeah you know I lived in Los
Angeles so I could see people around me
who were breaking through and I knew
that it was possible and so I just kept
at it I come over to Janice's after work
we she cooks dinner we ate dinner we
talk about right now well right now
we're in kind of a rewrite phase so
we're in a place where we
conceptualizing some of the
relationships so we'll kind of have
those kinds of discussions over dinner
and then we'll go downstairs and we'll
look at the board and that's more of a
plotting kind of figuring out how these
new relationships are going to fit into
our new plot yeah so and it usually
always involves chocolate and some
coloring that's our muse
[Laughter]
whether I'm a screenwriter or some other
form of creative I think one of the key
disciplines is to understand the
discipline is key and that is to say
when you when you you you should find
out what works best for you are you a
morning person are you a late night
writer I'm I'm not creative late at
night I like being up but I'm not create
I write like a theme when I when I have
that early morning coffee because all
night has been percolating for me that's
not true for everybody but if that's who
you are then make damn certain you've
going to bed at a reasonable hour and
then you're up and you've done gotten
your stuff done and now at 6:00 in the
morning or 7:00 in the morning or
whatever it is you've set aside and you
turn your phone off and you have
absolutely sort of put these puppets
soundproof walls around you literally
and figuratively so that you have two to
three hours of intensely productive time
on a consistent daily basis you do that
because it's a game of inches and if you
do that instead of being the person
who's laboring over a script and
rewriting it three years and you know
non-stop or you're doing a lot of first
drafts and you're on your 12th script
this year
those are not the indicators of success
but if you're someone who's got that
kind of discipline and you say how much
can i how much can i improve this we
know that rewriting is writing but up to
a point you know so how many drafts you
know if I can do this every day and then
I set it aside move on to the next one
and they come back to that with proper
inspiration but if you do that what you
can accomplish in a short one year
period will put to shame most people who
don't have that discipline who don't
know themselves and give themselves a
framework to be productive you have to
be disciplined it one of the great
stories of discipline perhaps the most
disciplined writers I ever heard of was
a man named Stephen Cannell passed away
a few years ago became incredibly
successful I mean if you could get a
show on TV you're successful if you get
multiple series
on TV that's beyond successful Stephen
Cannell created or co-created 40
television series for oh that's
unbelievable
he wrote or co-wrote 450 episodes of
television imagine if you just think
about that I know it just sounds like a
large number but if you write 15 scripts
a year that get produced for 30 years
amazing
Stephen Cannell came and spoke to my
students several years ago and said I am
severely dyslexic I flunked out of the
third grade I flunked out of the eighth
grade if I can make it you can make it
but he's skiing was he said I'm the
smartest guy in the room I'm not the
most talented guy in the room on the
hardest working guy in the room and when
cattle got out of college he had a day
job at his family's furniture business
and then wrote from 5 p.m. to 10 p.m.
every day Monday through Friday were put
in a full day writing Saturday and a
half day Sunday he did this for six
years until he got a job and I'll never
forget him saying but the thing is at
the end of every year when I looked back
I was that much better and it was just
odd to hear him talk about that and he
just he had to you had to keep
practicing there's a theory in general
not just about writing but about any
kind of pursuit that it takes 10,000
hours of practice to become an expert at
something tennis piano computer
programming writing that's a long time
that's you know if you practice 20 hours
a week for 50 weeks a year that's a
thousand hours so my 9 years probably
was not too far off what the that metric
was for getting good at it so it is
really difficult in the beginning and a
lot of writers have this fantasy or this
illusion and I did and I was wrong is
that you know you're you're working and
you're making money and you know and
you're trying to write and you're so
busy and writing so hard and and it god
when you sell something when you get
hired then you can quit your day job and
you can quit this you can just write an
oh what a luxury that would be because
you're so time starved but when you
first break when I first broke in the
business you know I had two months to
right the script for metropolis but
almost every day I had meetings and I
had to go in meetings and I was talking
about other projects and pitching and I
actually was spending more time on that
than I was on my day job so I actually
had left time to write and you had just
pulled in so many directions and so
discipline really matters I didn't have
TV I had uh it was really it's really
depressing I had this season of the
office that I would watch over and over
and over again and so like I didn't
really have anything to do except for
sit there and and write which was the by
design you know I didn't get cable I'd
you know I just wanted to work and it
was actually easier then to write and
say you know when you're happy with a
girlfriend and you know it's like that's
that's the hardest time for me to write
is when I'm you know happy and busy when
I just moved back from New York and I
love living in New York there's so much
to do it's hard for me to write New York
because I'm always distracted by you
know things that are going on outside
you know or what's my roommate doing
down there you know it sounds like he's
having fun you drinking beer let me have
some beer
so you know sometimes that that that
lonely time it's actually easier when I
went to work with with Michael McDowell
on bilges we had been working for a
couple of weeks and he sat down and he
said Larry this is not working out this
is not happening and I was taken aback
and I said why what do you mean he said
because you're just sitting around
waiting for inspiration and I don't work
like that I'm not I'm not going to sit
around waiting for you to be inspired if
you're going to work with me and Michael
is his professional writer as I've ever
met he had published
I don't know 19 20 novels novels
genre novels he had written for a show
called tales from the dark side he was
the real deal and
and and not a not not a pro not not a
person to to hold back his feelings okay
ne ne ne ne said to me this is just not
happening and he said and this was the
most this changed my my life as a writer
he said if you're going to work with me
look at it like we're working in a bank
we get in at 9:00 we have a cup of
coffee we say good morning we then we go
to work and we were and we write until
lunch we go have our lunch we come back
we write again till around three o'clock
in the afternoon we fold up the writing
we return whatever phone calls whatever
business of writing we have to do and we
do this five six days a week and we rant
and it's a job if it's not you sitting
in it with a metaphorical beret in a
metaphorical loft waiting for
inspiration to strike it's a job and it
was a bit of tough love and it took me
back and and I was I suppose a tiny bit
offended but then then the thing he said
to me that sealed the deal because I
when I was working at Paramount I was
writing script notes again it was it was
like a 16-hour day often and in probably
fourteen of those hours a day with
writing script notes and he said Larry
you've told me you've written hundreds
of pages of notes for other people's
scripts why can't you do it for yourself
and I was like wow okay I will try it
your way and it changed my perception of
who a writer is what a writer does and
it changed my work habits and it changed
everything and I did it his way and I
took all of that all and he was
absolutely right all of that discipline
that I'd put into other people's work
I put in I started putting the my work
on work and and and and it was and
buildings came out of that and is crazy
and you know and as far out of that
movie is the script was written in a
very disciplined way because that was
the way Michael needed to work people
always say like how can you be so
disciplined to just sit in your office
and write all the time well I don't
write all the time if it's artists and
and but I would say if I don't write it
doesn't happen not like going into an
office and having a job and and having
specific tasks and things like that and
having meetings set up for you I mean
you know if you're if you write a
writing on a TV staff is a little
different but if you basically writing
whether it's on spec or writing on
assignment and you're in your own space
you have to have to get the work done
you have to create you know your
schedule so I find that when I'm on a
tighter deadlines I write much more I
write much faster I'm up earlier I up
later I a certain amount of adrenaline
takes over where you just get it done if
I'm not on an assignment I'm writing
something for myself or I've got a
little time for something or I'm
preparing for a meeting that a week ago
a way instead of tomorrow I'll take a
little bit more time but basically every
day you know I'm always in work mode and
I'm always working on something writing
something putting pitches together
working on rewriting I always go back
and rewrite old scripts that I think
still have life in them that we can
maybe try to try to sell as the scripts
have strange lives so then they've nine
lives in some respects because you can
write something and I have scripts I've
written 10 even 15 years ago that didn't
sell then but suddenly there's a reason
that something's out in the zeitgeist
now that if I just make some tweaks and
sort of you know modernize a little bit
or updated it may have a life to it and
I did that a lot so when I have a little
downtime I always go back to the old
scripts but I've I've had a long I have
had a long stretch of a pretty regular
assignment work so that has kind of kept
me in a pretty you know pretty dedicated
and consistent work mode but you know I
I let's go this way
much happier and much saner when I'm
writing a lot you know and free time
free time is fine but I do I just enjoy
having having that project that I'm
working on so so I try to write as much
as I can whatever jobs I've had I've
been organized and even in school as
organized you know not like you know
fanatically but you know I'm pretty good
it's sort of knowing how to get things
done in a quick way and and not lose too
much time
you know prioritizing is very important
and because when you have a limited
amount of time to get something done you
really have to you have to kind of folk
be careful that you're not getting lost
in the minutiae of things and really
stay focused on the bigger picture and
that overarching story and the bigger
structure of something then then playing
with every little word you can get soul
as a writer you can get so lost in the
in in what some tie no one's very
accurately called swirling the words you
know where you just you know you get the
script written and then you stand all
this kind making every word perfect and
you know rearranging things and you know
we all want things to be as great as
what we consider perfect as possible but
then the movie gets made and there are
millions of changes along the way and
tons of things are cut and sometimes you
know what's being done sometimes you
don't know what's being done so you have
to really not over the course of time
I've learned to to really manage the
time I spend on things and not get too
caught up in the minutia of things which
is kind of easy to do so but I'm pretty
good at organization and getting things
done and I'm fairly quick and I can
write fairly quick I can rewrite fairly
quickly over the course of time I
perseverate a lot less on honest on a
script or a story or a pitch I wanted to
like I said I wanted to be great but I
kind of I'm so good at letting things
breathe and evolve a little bit more to
get to the point that they need to be
and I will say there's a collective
consciousness of work focus so if you
have four or five people who are really
writing in an environment and you know
they're screenwriters and you know that
that's what they're doing
you're going to kind of feel compelled I
feel or at least I did I felt compelled
to really write you know and I'd say
okay you need to do at least 10 pages a
day you know in ten pages seems like a
lot but I would take the pressure off of
myself I think they can suck
but you still didn't ages a day I'd say
in my most prolific time a writing day
is literally getting up in a very
discipline way and writing for four or
five hours or more straight I would get
up and consistently go to coffee shops
and maybe show up around 10:00 or 11:00
a.m. and I'd start writing you know I
you know mess around on Facebook or
whatever and then after I procrastinated
for 30 or 40 minutes of it like okay you
got to get through it now and so then I
would write for about four or five six
hours maybe take a break have some lunch
and then I'd write again until like late
in the in the evening and then I'd go to
the gym go home and do it all over again
and there were like very specific coffee
houses around LA and there would just be
the usual suspects
so you see other writers screenwriters
you'd also see like maybe students but
mostly after well you'd see the same
kind of screenwriters and there was one
guy who was a storyboard artist and he
was getting into the whole digital thing
and so he would be there every night
doing his storyboard art digitally or
whatever and we would all that we'd like
all know each other so we'd have to
sometimes find different different
coffee shops because it would become
slightly more social you know it's like
a fan I want anyone to talk to me right
now because I really just want to focus
well writing I think is very different
than being in the production side of it
writing I like to do a 9 to 5 like
usually 11 to 8 like I'm not I like to
structure my days so that I'm writing it
like an office job which is kind of
funny in a way because you kind of do
this job because you don't like the
office job but I like that kind of
structure because I like to be able to
have an end point for relaxation it
doesn't always work that way but like
relaxation meaning like watching movies
or just like thinking about something
else other than project because I think
that's so important just to stay like in
life as well so yeah I'll get up and all
you know sit in front of my computer not
fighting for a couple of hours then
write something maybe and go make some
lunch and come back and not write
something for a while and then go back
you know and then you just kind of start
and stop like any job and just do that
consistently though but you know five
days a week for sure
honestly I think it's a it's a
double-edged sword because you can
justify a lot of goofing off during the
writing process as letting the creative
juices flow and build and letting your
mind wander a bit you know that the
truth is story not so much story telling
but story creating happens in the
subconscious and sometimes if you just
sit there and you stare at a computer
screen or you stare at a blank piece of
paper waiting for words to come it's a
more forced artificial process whereas
you know sitting in a park watching
people interact you might get an idea
for something on the other hand you can
waste way too much time doing that so
it's a double-edged sword and you have
to find a way to to discipline yourself
and you know that's going to be
different for everybody the way I do it
is to set myself a page quote I have to
write a certain number of pages each day
and if I've wasted time on the internet
or in pointless Facebook debates which
seem to occupy an increasingly large
amount of time you know I don't let
myself get up I don't let myself go to
bed or whatever I don't leave the
computer until I've reached that quota
so that's that that's really the only
way for me that's uh that's really
proven to be effective because otherwise
you know I'll write one good little bit
and I'll be all proud of myself and then
I'll go do something else and at the end
of the day I discovered that well that
was a good bit but it was only half a
page and now I have ten pages to write
tomorrow instead of five so so keeping
to a daily quota is really something
that's been effective for me most
writers that I work with
have a amount of pages per day they want
to achieve but I think that's like
asking how you make love I mean you as
long as you get your pages in the day I
think there's one right artwork cook at
home heater nobody in the world can work
at this more than two hours a day if
they say they are they're lying and but
I don't think that's true I know other
writers I've worked with who literally
crank out the chapters on a discipline
basis we just did a book from an English
woman who's a brilliant writer but she's
a financial analyst she turned her book
in to the publisher on time and the
publisher was the gas like we never have
that well it's just she's used to
actually having to produce stuff on a
schedule I can't emphasize enough though
that the discipline of a professional
writer to go ahead and and and always
fulfil the page count for the day is it
sounds mind-numbing it sounds like
working in a factory I'm just observing
those are the writers who succeed I
don't know why that is
but they are the writers who succeed I
have a deadline I must produce I'm
producing it now they all do that why is
that I don't know why do the ones that
say ah you know I I'm not inspired today
well I'll just watch a movie or I'll do
something fun with research and the
inspiration will come I don't know why
those guys never finished their script I
don't know why I'm not judging I'm just
observing who sells scripts and who
doesn't that's my observation I've said
before that I do not believe in mornings
because I've never seen one i my day
actually you know it's like 10 o'clock
when I'm drinking my first cup of coffee
going by our lives and then probably in
like the noon to 2:00 is when I start to
do the writing thing I my thing is when
I'm I try to write five pages a day five
good pages a day and some days those are
short days because if you just comes
right on and other days it's like I'm
taking pair of pliers and pulling the
words out one by one from my brain and
you know sometimes they're long days one
of my rules is not to reward myself for
failure and if that means that if if I
don't make my five pages I don't get to
eat ice cream I don't get my dessert you
know I that's those are those are
rewards I don't go see a movie if I
don't get my five pages done if I do my
old route in the valley used to leave me
at a coffee Coffee Bean and Tea Leaf
that's right across from the AMC Burbank
and so if I finish my five pages I would
walk across the street and see a movie
as my reward if I didn't do my five
pages I'd go home and you know I think
sometimes people this is a weird writer
thing is we get depressed if we fail and
then when we get depressed we go for
comfort food we're going to get a gallon
of ice cream and that's the wrong
message to send yourself plus eating a
gallon of ice cream probably isn't good
for you but you know the the thing is
like if you fail to me if I fail to make
my five pages
I don't reward myself when I was working
in the warehouse my thing was one page a
day and if I write if you write one page
a day every day
that's three spec scripts by the end of
the year so I when people say I've been
working on the script for the past five
years I go what are you doing write five
words a day you know what is the you
know you need to put in a little more
effort there the other thing is when
you're writing professionally there are
deadlines and some of them are crazy so
you have to be prepared to be able to
write against the clock in a lot of ways
it's harder to write your own script
because there's nobody there's nobody
providing parameters guidelines so you
know you can do anything and that means
you have to
control yourself you have to narrow
yourself down everyday you have to be
your own sort of critic and and that
that requires thinking in a lot of
different ways whereas when you know you
have an approved storyline and this is
what they want and you just have to
deliver it in some ways that that's a
lot easier because there there are fewer
decisions to make at every turn on the
other hand that first script I had to
write 200 miles-per-hour
from the day they gave me the assignment
that needed to be done in 10 days so and
I I never written a feature script that
quickly before so that wasn't that was
an interesting challenge I was basically
chained to my computer 12 hours a day
plain how springy spring cleaning and
you know reading books that I've been on
the gel for years like I'm going to read
this book I'm planning to read it for
good years I'm going to read it now I'm
like really really you need to be
writing what are you doing but um yeah
you do everything to get out of it and
but once I'm in there you know that's
the crazy part it's like once you're in
there you're in there just get in there
but that's easier said than done if you
have certain scenes inside of you that
you see visually that are sort of the
tent poles for the story by all means
write those down and then write what
works up to it and what Springs off of
them but if you get to a certain place
where you're only writing what you love
you're being a little undisciplined you
know at that point you have to go
alright I have to start writing the
scenes that I don't know or don't love
as well then start from the beginning
and start moving toward those key scenes
that you've already written I do think
that we all have little chip tricks that
we play where we write only things that
we love you know or or or that we're
good at you know I've watched a lot of
writers that will write scene after
scene and I'm like yeah I know you can
do this okay where's that scene that's
really hard for you write that so it's
not a question of not being disciplined
so much
as you know not wanting to be taken to
task for not not being wonderful right
away if you're your own boss you have to
be you can be the nice boss but you also
have to be the mean boss you have to be
the boss that when you're slacking off
cracks the whip and said you got to get
back to work and people this is the
fantasy that writers have or you know
that non writers have about writing is
that once I quit my day job I never have
to deal with idiot bosses producers I
never have to you know I can I can sleep
as late as I want which is fine as long
as you get the work done and I never
have to actually like punch a time clock
or anything like that you now have to
punch your own time clock you've got to
manage your day so you get work done
because if you don't get the work done
you you're going to end up at the end of
your time going I don't have a script to
go out and the rents due you know I've
got I've got to make some sale I've got
to do something I've got a shake up I'll
usually expect to shake up the world so
you get meetings and you know if you've
got a you got to get scripts done you've
got to be the mean boss
script that I wrote the first one that
was too dirty according to the agent
there actually I got the idea for this
script because I was being an absolute
pain in the neck to my wife because I
was unemployed and we just had a baby
and I thought I was a failure and I
wasn't supporting my family and we're
actually having an argument about this
at 11 o'clock at night where she says
you've got this free time why don't you
write something now and just once you
rewrite through a feature script I said
well I'm not ready to do that she said
well then write a cheers episode I said
well I would but I haven't had any ideas
wait I just got an idea it was bizarre
in the middle of an argument I went over
my desk was in our bedroom at that time
as a table and a kitchen table goes in
our bedroom and I wrote notes and said
okay I'll do this starting tomorrow and
I wrote the script in a week and then
called up the agent said okay I've
written another script and it really got
my agent interested in representing me
even though he had reservations about
that particular script he clearly said
this guy can write comedy so that that's
what I did when I was unemployed I would
write it was too difficult to write with
a family and a 12 hour a day job but but
it was a job that had periods of
unemployment and so I tried not to be
lazy during those times the mornings
good you wake you do have less things
going on in the morning nighttime I used
to really be able to get into a place at
night but I think it's mostly worrying
about getting up in the morning that
keeps me from writing late into the
night as much as I used to more and more
I think I'm getting into a place where I
you know with practice you get to a
place where you can just kind of dive in
from almost anywhere I mean I can pretty
much write on the train if I can get a
seat attention I can't write when I'm
driving so that's annoying
but I can kind of curl up anywhere and
get a few words I can't write and I know
you know it's funny because I do know
like I'll have like a pad in the
passenger side and like I keep a pen I
keep pads and pens like hidden all over
the house and anywhere and there are
times when like
something will hit me and I'm just like
okay I can read it but please I can't
the writing though I mean that's the
beauty of the laptop you can go anywhere
so if you're trying to write quickly and
try not to think too much
I do need a quiet space I can write at
Starbucks can't do that whole whole I'll
write them exercises too much going on
but you know if I'm it you know I get
hard to edit and I have downtime in the
editing room or it's just me so it's
just like I crack at that laptop just
can just I can just shoot through it
again go fast it's harder to find time
to edit what I've written and reread it
and rewrite it because that requires
more focus then just being in the moment
and kind of shooting through it that way
I feel more inspired when the world is
quiet and the phones aren't ringing and
Twitter's not going off or the cellphone
isn't going off and I can kind of let my
imagination just run where it wants to
go because there's nothing distracting
and and I feel like even in the work
that I do as a journalist that's when I
get my inspiration I'm a little bit more
relaxed and I'm not I'm actually not as
self-conscious at night as I am in a day
something about the lights being on and
the light being up makes me a little
more just have to be this way and I
think I can play in my mind at night
better now I have a follow-up question
to that because I I know that Janice is
somebody who will say I'm going to go to
bed I'm going to set my alarm for like 2
or 3 a.m. and I'm going to get up and
I'm going to work so when you say you
work better at night is it you stay
awake all through the day and then at
night you find that place or are you
talking about when you've gotten up
basically still in the middle of the
night yeah when I've gotten up in the
know like I'll set my alarm for like 2
or 3 o'clock and I'll get up and usually
like I'll have a shower so I'm feeling
kind of relaxed and comfortable and I
think when the shower starts well
well by water or with water I get
inspired because I'm not really thinking
about what I'm supposed to be writing
but the characters start coming alive to
me and and then because I do keep a pad
in my bathroom needs are right and and
then I go downstairs or go in my bedroom
or stay in my bedroom and just kind of
write things out and kind of freehand
things so yeah I think being in an
atmosphere where I don't feel like I
have to write right at a desk or a
computer I free write a lot by hand so
and then I take that and then put it on
the computer
oh yeah so in that way we're actually
pretty similar because it's almost like
you're a morning writer it's just
because because I'm the same way I get
up in the morning and although I don't
shower or do anything I can't I of the
Edith Wharton School where I just kind
of opened might like stay in bed open my
laptop and then just start working
because the minute I go outside and see
like the sink is full of dishes I'm like
maybe we'll do a few dishes or something
like that but if you just like kind of
stay in squalor ensconced in your bed
you can get a fair amount done before
you have to really face the world
I have a trick if we have a deadline I
generally just use that you're faster I
think I think I read once that that's
what you I could be wrong but I think
that Ethan cone is the faster type or so
a lot of the type that's what I've read
anyway but I'm but he is he's like a
magician so there's a deadline I usually
use it and he's completely onto it so
he'll you generally pushback or be like
now it's it's all you so it's it's a
it's a trick they use too many times but
I'll still pull it out every now and
then we are dealing with a cable company
like HBO or or Showtime or cinematics or
USA Network or lifetime or sci-fi
channel they have a big board that shows
you what movies are playing on there you
know for each these days I guess you'd
probably know about TV movies from
sci-fi channel and sharknado but it's
those like when the scheduled sharknado
2 they put it on the board for it's
going to show this night at this time
and I had a movie on you it was at my
movie there was a movie on USA Network
that was on their big board that fell
apart and so I got a call from a
producer who said they had a movie that
fell out at the last moment we need to
make the movie for them what are we
going to make and so I would end pitched
ideas to them and they they had a
location that was the interesting thing
is they had a location called the Orcutt
ranch in the valley which is a gigantic
orange orchard with a Hacienda on it and
all kinds of cool stuff it's a city you
know city owns it and they rent it out
for basically weddings and so I toured
the property went back pitched three or
four ideas they picked one and after
they picked the idea they said you have
12 days to turn in your first draft and
here's the catch that first is the first
draft is going out to talent so the
actors we're going to try to get to take
reduced wages on this film not they're
not whether they get paid but less than
that are going to be reading your 12 day
first draft and I said okay and I wrote
the script in ten days had two days left
they were to do a rewrite and those were
that's
my suggestion for anyone working in an
insane deadline is always leave two days
to do a rewrite no matter what the same
deadline is because those two days I
made that script a million times better
than the first draft and it went out
they cast a oscar-nominated actress and
the female lead to work way below her
rate and you know that it ended up being
cool
the other one was even worse was a a
Roger Corman movie I did about robot
hookers from outer space and I had nine
days to write it the film was shot in
nine days and it played on Showtime for
nine days Corman how to deal with
Showtime at time played on Showtime for
nine days so it was nine days to write
nine days to shoot the nine days on
Showtime then it was out of there we
stopped when we're on deadline yes
always that point like before we have to
turn it in there's like okay and then
you just back engineer it you're like
okay here's where we're going to have to
turn it in so here's where we're going
to have to send it to my mom to
spellcheck now or somebody it is dead
line yeah by the way who is looking at
it um well the deadline the deadline
that we're looking at right now is a
dream ago deadline from a screenwriting
standpoint though for us it does tend to
be definite the wheat have been pretty
much with all three years we've been
working on it on deadlines for something
either a competition or our producing
partner has a deadline where he would
like to see you know a certain thing
done so we've tended to write to
deadlines most yeah you don't always
know you're writing to deadlines at the
beginning you're like oh we have so much
time we're just writing and then the
deadline gets closer when there's a
deadline it's a lot easier to force
yourself to just stay there you know you
know how many pages you have to write on
average each day to to be finished by
the date they set for you and if you're
not making that quota you know you're
screwing up and someday you're going to
be up 24 hours straight trying to make
up for it so it's when you've got a
deadline it's a lot of you
year two to discipline yourself at the
same time my in my experience
screenwriting is 80% surfing the web
doing dishes walking the dog
all the while hopefully you're thinking
about what you're going to be writing
and then 20% of the time you're actually
typing away what I learned is that when
you have an insane deadline like that
you write fast you cut through to your
subconscious completely you basically
it's a direct line instead of your brain
going well I don't know if that that
seems too personal all of those blocks
that you usually put between you and
writing can't be there you now have to
produce pages and so you end up writing
a more personal script a more a script
gets right into the icky stuff inside of
us we don't want to deal with because
you don't have time to put up the walls
there's just no time for the walls so
you write fast you come up with I think
a better script and if I have a deadline
I know when something has to be done and
I'm it's a paying job I'm a pretty harsh
taskmaster when I'm writing a spec
script for myself I tend to go a bit
easier on myself on the theory that
creativity is what's most important here
I'm not on deadline and I don't need to
meet somebody else's schedule and I
should just let it flow but again that's
you know that's really just self
justification and there's a huge amount
I think there's a huge amount of
laziness involved in being the screener
Pfeiffer to be honest with you
it really depends on the writer so there
isn't one set course that you're
supposed to follow but it really is
about doing the work and then getting
the work out there sometimes you'll work
on a script and you'll say you know I've
worked on this for eight months I've
tackled it every which way it's not
happening so it's also knowing when to
let something go not for all eternity
but potentially to come back to it later
when you've had a stroke of genius then
informs you how to take the work how to
make it better you know but the point
with having those broad goals is to just
do the work and get it out there rather
than spend years and years and years
tinkering with one screenplay then
you're out of the risk of after three
years and I just want through this with
a writer tinkering with the same script
for three years and then going oh it's
not good enough it'll never be good
enough I'm not going to get it out there
and then starting another script and
spending another two years on something
and then going oh but it's still not
good enough I'm not going to get this
out there that is the challenge that we
run into that so because of that you
really want to expose the work early and
often so that means from concept you
want to run the concept by people in the
know whether they're members of your
writers group or in a class or whatever
it is have people look at your outline
and really don't be afraid to expose the
work to get feedback to have questions
asked
I was just sitting with a writer of mine
who had written a script a feature
script with the guidance of his manager
and they had been on the script for a
year and a half and then he gave the
script to a few writer friends and he
got some massive notes back and what he
said to me of only we've given it out on
outline which is what we all were
pushing him to do but he felt loyal to
the manager he didn't want to expose it
and I understand I understand the choice
that he made it within in a tough spot
do you listen do you serve the one
master or do you open yourself up I
generally prefer to expose work early
and often because I think it just saves
you a lot of time in the end when I
wrote my book when I had trimmed it down
nice and tight and I thought I really
had it ready to go I had a hundred and
hundred and twenty hundred and thirty
thousand words
the manuscript and I called him up and
said okay I'm ready to go I've done my
cutting and I've done them to it you
know here it is 130,000 words and he
laughed publisher laughed and said no no
Eric we don't publish anything over
70,000 words and it was like this boat
of horror that hit me I said wait a
minute are you actually telling me that
I now have to cut my book in half and he
said yeah actually I'm afraid I am so
for three or four days I was just
practically in a coma but you know any
writer you know you're just you're
appalled but well what they make you to
do to your babies and then I got some
help I had somebody else a dear dear
friend who was good with editing take a
look at it and I seriously cut into it
one more time for editing I got it down
to 82 thousand words not quite there 70
thousand but I cut it by 4045 percent of
the book that I thought was absolutely
necessary was gone and the book was
better for it it was such a better book
it was clearer and it was cleaner and
there were so many swamps removed from
it it was an interesting experience but
I had did not realize you know you have
to reject for I didn't realize how much
work that was yet to be done so writing
is word choices and a process of really
cool too which means writers never write
alone never but what we spend a lot of
time alone in the writing process but
once we have something then we have to
and this is important this is important
too to new writers everywhere you have
to have a circle of people whose opinion
of material you trust it's one of the
things that happens in our program these
people make friends for life
because then they rely on each other's
judgement because everybody knows
everybody's opinion grows to become
quite sophisticated about the material
and you can always call up one of your
buddies and say you want to do a script
swap you know you read mine I read yours
and what you get back frequently is not
what you want to hear we're all children
and we all want to say oh that is the
greatest thing isn't that great and
that's never what you hear so you're
always eternally disappointed so you
hear objective good criticism of what
you've got and I always tell them 48
hours don't do anything for 48 hours
suffer fine you stay in bed whatever you
need to do in response to what you've
heard about your material and then sit
down and read it again cover to cover
and it will be revealed to you through
someone else's point of view what you
really have and all of a sudden it's
time to start editing again and
rewriting again you will get it and that
is what has happened there is the cycle
of subjective work to re objectification
because it's the more you work on
something over time the more you are in
it you are drawn into it and it becomes
within you and it is about you and you
think you're doing something great and
then you take it out and you get a slap
in the face or two you get you clears
your eyes it clears your vision very
very well you become reified and you
approach the material again with clean
eyes for another go-round and in my
experience if you really want good
material and I'm assuming we all do
there some we just want Pat's on the
head and all kind of stuff but if you
really want the material to be good you
have to go through that cycle
subjectivity re objectification
subjectivity we have four or five maybe
six times then then each time you know
it gets better and it gets a little
better and it gets a little better and
you don't want to send any
it's one of the biggest mistakes people
make sending out material before it's
finished as a lot all the storytellers
and all the artists out there know
especially in LA there's this really
weird pushing pull between your own
intuition and then also this other thing
of like feedback you know people will
tell you that won't sell what that
doesn't translate or these are the rules
or you don't do that I think my initial
kind of primal intuition has always been
a little bit more rebellious
I don't like Authority I don't like
being told you can do this I've always
been interested in some things that are
like left-of-center per se so I think
you know my intuition you know has been
challenged so many times because people
will come and say well that doesn't
really work you know or that is kind of
not how you do it so it's been kind of
an interesting journey or a struggle
because I I do think that somewhere
along the way because filmmaking is a
collaborative process and you have to
like open yourself up to suggestions and
different perspectives but at the same
time I do think that storytellers and
artists and filmmakers or whoever actors
writers you have to open up the windows
a little bit for perspective and
feedback but you also have to be be
really mindful of what your internal
kind of voices and and so to answer your
question sometimes I feel like I'm
really good with my instincts and
sometimes I'm I'm really proud of it and
sometimes I don't know because I haven't
been able to test a lot of things in the
marketplace you know I mean you and I
off-camera we talked a little bit about
David Lynch and how you know I mean I'm
a big fan of his work and this is a guy
whose work is so specific and I'm such a
fan of his work
but he's been proven in the marketplace
and so people have an understanding that
that's his signature you know so people
will leave them alone you can do
whatever you want because there's a fan
base there you know but I think when
you're you know just sort of emerging in
the marketplace and you're trying to
figure out what your voice is what kind
of stories are interesting to you and
you don't have all the money and all the
access to people who can help you make
that vision come to life then you start
to make little compromises along the way
you know and then somewhere along the
way the magic of collaborating happens
where your movie can become better than
you expected but also somewhere along
the way you might start to like lose a
sense of your own voice because you
don't know whether you got a chance to
really experiment with that does that
make sense
you know I mean it's kind of a long
answer to your question no I think I
guess to answer your question I think
it's an ongoing ongoing thing that
happens with storytellers they didn't
respond to the writing as much as they
wanted to they really expected the pat
on the back and being told how great it
was and chances are it wasn't as good so
really it's up to you it depends on how
thick your skin is it's about how much
you want this and how much you're
conscious enough to understand that
feedback is important and that you
should take it as it is you should look
at as constructive criticism and and pay
attention to it and rewrite and make it
better it's all about making it better
and you really got to know how to do
it's big part of the Hollywood job you
know as a screenwriter you I mean you
know I've never heard of something being
just first draft you know it's always
draft I mean hunt you know 30 drafts 40
drafts you know so they're constantly
and you got to be able to do that if
you're the type of writer who does not
like to be told that something is wrong
and wants to say no this is the way it
is it's my art and that's worth it you
shouldn't be writing screenplays you
should be writing novels or put plays
that's really the only two professions
where the writer is keying really
unless you're doing television
television the writer is king there but
but mostly novelists and playwrights
were yeah the editor can tell you
something is not working and you could
take it or leave it but it's really you
have the final say on it then you should
do that but you know I think people who
have think skins or very sensitive about
creative feedback should not be
screenwriters I mean they're in for a
really you know very frustrating
experience if that's the case
when should a writer give up on a screen
like that it's such a good question
because I'm not sure you should ever
give up on a screenplay
but at the same time there's the point
where you should shelve it for a while
until you figure out what's wrong with
it and I have a bunch of scripts that I
fact this the spec script that I'm
working on now is a script that got
shelled because I couldn't figure it out
and it just it wasn't working and I put
it on the shelf and went on to do other
things I do this thing called
cross-training because when I'm not
writing one thing I'm writing something
else so often if I take the screenplay
that I can't figure out the answers to
put it on the shelf and write some other
things
I will then learn something that helps
me solve the problems with that
screenplay and so it's like there's I
have scripts that that have been on the
Shelf forever because I still haven't
figured it out other scripts that go on
the shelf I read a couple of scripts and
I figure out what the problem is but
giving up on a screenplay I don't know
there's always to me there's always
something of me in every screenplay so
it's it's you know do I want to give up
on my arm
no it's like you know I still my arm I
want to go back and figure out why my
art what's going on with my arm and make
it work again this gets to a Roman
Polanski's the tenant what right does my
head have to call itself me but yeah I
don't think you should ever give up on
the screenplay you should shelve it
though for a while and go on to
something else I think too often people
don't put their script aside and so what
they're doing is they don't know the
solution to the problem and they they
often just make it worse by rewriting
and rewriting without knowing how to get
out of it not knowing the solution to
the problem where if you put it aside it
allows you fresh eyes your mind goes off
if you're trying to remember a line to
some movie the best way to remember it
is try not to remember it so you know
trivia so if you're trying to figure out
the solution to a screenplay problem the
best thing to do is not try to figure
out how to solve it but go on to
something else and then you'll figure
out the solution sometime and you know
the script I'm working on right now is a
was a script that was originally
designed as a movie for Orion Pictures
at a producer who how to deal with the
Ryan Pictures
I had this grip that I pitched that he
said would go to treatment with the
treatment on the script and then Orion
Pictures went bankrupt the story of my
life and the script now that the
producer said well we can't do it for
that budget but we can do it on a
smaller budget so now take this script
that was a big script and turn it into a
small script and it didn't work that way
so the film never got made I bought the
rights back and it's been sitting on my
shelf as I've been waiting to figure out
how to turn it now in today's world into
a movie that's the bigger budget version
and it's it was it's like a North by
Northwest chase movie which at some
point in time got shrunk down to no
chase it just did not work but but that
trying to figure out the solution to
that problem took me a while so it took
me a decade of not thinking about it
writing is hard
creating is hard yeah I mean I'm
probably the biggest surprise in it
there it is we you know every writer
will relate to the experience of you
know trying to do anything else but
write you know the whole thing about
sharpening your pencils and doing your
laundry and cleaning your house and you
know entering emails or playing
solitaire you know on one hand it's
something that's advised because there's
that whole thing about the creative
process where you know we're talking the
gestation period where you're supposed
to think about your problem your
creative problem and then kind of ignore
it and do something else that unrelated
that helps creatively so people think
okay that means procrastination you can
do other things and there is some truth
to it the problem is is if you're
constantly afraid to write and so you're
trying to do other things then you'll
never write because you're just
constantly procrastinating so there's
got to be a point where you you've got
to put that aside and actually write so
you got to get over it and it's plenty
I mean online there's tons of advice
about procrastination and how to avoid
it because it's not just for writing
it's for everybody everybody for creston
AIDS
you know anything that's worthwhile to
do and it's scary to do people will
procrastinate bla because this really
means you're not writing it just means
your the words are not coming up and the
reason the words are not coming up
because fear is creating an attention
that prevents you from from writing you
know that's what it is so you know it's
like saying you know a plumber or
plumber Neff doesn't have plumbers block
right he's just got to do their job it's
about doing it's about doing your job
showing up at your at your job you have
to understand that writing is a job when
you get paid or not you got to show up
to your desk and you got to put your
butt on the chair and you got to type
words you know so that's what it is and
so we use that as an excuse we say well
it really is fear of writing fear of
whatever all those procrastinating
things I've said but it doesn't sound to
say oh I'm afraid it sounds a lot better
to say I'm blocked because then people
can go home for you oh yeah you're
you're an artist
hi you know so it sounds better but it's
really it's just fear you know and again
there's plenty of material out there
about how to overcome those fears so
it's all psychological stuff you stop -
come I will never go back to the
beginning because that is a death trap
I know what I'll do I'll go back and
rewrite the first 60 pages and then I'm
going to rewrite the first 60 pages
again and again I'll go back and read a
couple of pages and and and maybe do
some cosmetic stuff just to get you know
just to put myself back into the zone of
the story and then you just and then I
just start writing and they may not be
good ideas there may be my drafts are
always 2030 pages too long when I finish
the first draft because I'm telling the
story to myself uh but I I forget who it
was I'm going to say Oscar Wilde I'm
going to say son famous writer said just
sit down and start typing your name over
and over even Oscar Wilde made the pre
typewriter I bet but the you understand
the point start typing your name start
doing anything with your
and I and again it's it's like where
that comes from and where that next
scene comes from it's there it is there
and if you put yourself in a position to
find it you will find it and I might
spend a day writing ten basically bad
pages but there will be one page of
truth in it and one one moment that will
move the story forward and and Stephen
King talks about this really brilliantly
and he I have questions about outlining
and I'm not here to have an outline
debate
he's scathing about outlining if you've
ever read his book on writing great
probably the best book I'm writing ever
written into my mind but he always says
it's what happens next it's what happens
next what happens next one happens next
and you know if I were to reach across
the room here and and steal your pate
your notes from you there would be a
response yeah that or if I were to kick
the camera over today I'm done with this
interview there would be a response
right and then it's what happens next do
you jump on me and say give me my notes
back you jerk to you I mean and it's
really that is it kind of gets it and if
you just look at it like that that that
and you look at it like like whatever
whatever you made happen something has
to happen next and it's what happens
next what happens next what happens next
what happens next that what happens next
will come and it may not come easily and
there may be a lot of like I said bad
what happens next before you find the
right what happens next
but it'll come and it's it and it's a
magical process
I mean magical in the sense that that it
it's almost unexplainable and it's why
and it's why there's so many
screenwriting programs and apps and and
and all of these things out there to
kind of tell you that they can tell you
what happens next but they can't tell
you what happens next only you can tell
you what happens next and I look at as a
moment-by-moment process and I put these
characters in a situation and it's often
diabolical and it's often otherworldly
and they've got to get themselves either
deeper into it or get the hell out of it
and that's the journey and it's moment
by moment and it's and it's it's sort of
literally second-by-second if you think
about it you know movies move forward in
a linear fashion if you're not on a
schedule you're not on a timetable or
you're not watching the clock it's very
easy to get lost now by the same token
I'm I'm a good believer like sometimes
you just have to just write stuff out
and just you know have it in your head
and just get it down in the page and not
edit yourself to sort of you know like
like blow it out and I think sometimes
that's very helpful to get to be to the
essence to find the essence of what
you're really trying to do but I I think
you know I I think I think it comes just
an experiment with experience frankly I
think it's really just the more things
you've written and the more ways you
understand how to how to best tell and
structure a story so that it'll be the
most effective that it'll hit the marks
that somebody you're somebody's hiring
you is looking for you know if you're
working for a film company or network or
producer who has certain paradigms
mandates things that work best for them
you know you focus on those things
because there's just some some when
you're writing for other people
sometimes there's so much you can of
yourself that can be in that script you
know you have you know you're trying to
try to fill a number of boxes and it's a
little different than just writing
something on spec or like writing a
stage play which is which is for you so
you learn how to adjust the amount of
time you spend on things what you focus
on what is important what probably less
important what's going to change was
probably not going to change because we
have a finite amount of time to do
things Barrington's got the energy
that little bunny with the batteries I
love you know I have pretty good like
you know one time on task I have a I
have a certain amount of persistence for
that and I think you don't really know
what's slowing you down sometimes I'm
sure it works both ways I think you know
sometimes Janice will like we'll be
working on something that maybe feels
like it's a little bit off topic or
something and I tend you know and I'm
always trying to like pare away
and like you know I have less patience
for that kind of thing because I'm like
I want to be writing and so like I'm
tired of talking about things I want to
be writing but she's like that late I
need to tell you this and this and also
I made me think about this and I'm like
it's too much but then when you get to
the page you never know what you might
need you know and that's and and so
sometimes like things that I was
impatient in the moment about I'm like
oh that little detail is totally going
to make it so and and you don't know how
long it would have taken you to come up
with that if you hadn't you know taking
the time to do that groundwork so yeah
so it's just a time-consuming process
running screenplays a time-consuming
process I think the best part of writing
a script is when you actually you've
actually written enough of the beginning
the middle and the end that you have
visualized the whole entire puzzle in a
certain way so now you're just along for
the ride and it's not it's not like
painful and hard and try to figure
anything out you've figured it out now
it's just like I'm going to sit down and
write this team or I'm going to put that
scene I'm going to put this scene here
I'm gonna put this in here because I
think of screenwriting like a puzzle I
very rarely write in chronicle
chronological order I will literally
write a theme that I know is going to be
in the movie I might write the ending I
mean I literally and then I'll start
moving on
the scene goes here the singles here now
some people do that with index cards
like though right put put the thing
together with index cards I just do it
in the script I just cut and paste and
put that scene there and I'll like write
a scene and then just go more more more
knowing that I'm going to write more
scenes there but knowing that I need to
write that scene so I think once you
have actually I guess it's a confidence
thing once you're confident that you
know the story and the characters and
they're going to you know it's like hey
I can see Vegas we're going to get there
it's right there there the lights and
everything I'm in Barstow alright
everybody is right that's like the most
exciting part there's a little
bittersweet thing it's great to finish
like yes of course you love to finish
but a little bittersweet thing to
finishing it's sort of like finishing a
good book you're like oh my god no right
no what am I going to do
is there more than is no it's over like
it's done
so there's a little bit of something
that you know and I think people feel
that when they read a really good book
and they're just like wow do I I'm not
going to see those characters again and
that was amazing and but it's done I
think it's the book that scares people
it depends but often I see it in sort of
the rewrite process where you have spit
out that first draft where you have
written the scenes that you love and
then there's this you know a problem
area that you have to tackle and first
of all figuring out how to fix it that's
that's hard but even when you know how
to fix it sometimes it's not what you
want to do and it's but you have to that
is the place where it's hardest I think
but once you get passed through a test
pass bad through that I think that it's
probably the most rewarding because you
really did the hard work you wake up a
Monday morning with your cup of coffee
and you've gone to work
and you have no idea what what needs to
happen next in your script or story I
tell about this almost always in my
classes was from Beal Jews where there's
a scene that a lot of people love
actually it's become like a lot of
people one of their favorite scenes and
the ghost Barbara Barbara Adam Geena
Davis and Alec Baldwin
they died they've driven off a bridge
trying to avoid a dog aren't they good
people they tried to avoid the doggy and
they drove it off a bridge and they
drown and they're trapped in their house
now as ghosts and they've been given a
book about how to the handbook for the
recently deceased that they can't make
that they can't figure it out and they
want to go into the afterlife and ask
questions about how to be ghosts and how
they're supposed to live it you know
live as ghosts as it dies goes whatever
and and but but what Michael my writing
partner Michael McDowell on I had done
is we'd trapped them so well in their
house we had no idea how to get them
into the afterlife we had done a very
good job of sticking them there what
with what felt like no exit and we had
to come up with a way for them to get
out of the house and the dynamic between
yet you got to understand Michael was
I'm going to say harvard-educated if not
Harvard some incredibly prestigious
university I I grew up in a trailer park
and barely got out of high school okay
there was there there was there was a
sometimes it was usually usually playful
but sort of a status issue between us
and and the way we'd often work is that
I would like vomit out ideas and he
would just start shooting them down and
it was always one word no no no no and
we were trying to come up with a way to
get them out of house Barbara and Adam
the ghost get them into the afterlife
and I was coming up with more and more
convoluted ideas about how to get them
out of the
house and I'm sure trying to bring out
my supernatural chops and all that I
knew about you know metaphysics and
blah-de-blah
just to get them out of the house and
every idea I came up with no no no and
my ideas kept getting further and
further out and more convoluted no no no
and I finally got really angry with
Michael and I said Michael what do you
want them to do draw an effing door and
I just said it because I thought it was
a stupidest idea imaginable and I was so
mad as is that what you want you want
them to draw door and he just started
laughing then when I started laughing we
said yes that's exactly what they should
do is draw a door so rather than these
incredibly like these convoluted
supernatural nonsense
Adam found a piece of chalk drew a door
drew a doorknob opened it and went into
the afterlife simple but it took all of
that convoluted stuff to get there and
that's what will happen when you sit
down and you're stuck you will write and
write and write and you won't think you
found it and you'll know you haven't
found it but if you keep at it and you
keep writing they'll finally be that
epiphany moment and you'll go oh that's
what happens next and then you will
write that and you will have moved your
characters forward one more step in your
story and then the next what happens
next is in front of your eyes and you
move forward like that and it's
sometimes it's literally moving an inch
or less than an inch at a time and
sometimes it's running sometimes it's
crawling sometimes - what happens next
happen really quickly and you have a day
where you just go oh my god you know I
just you know I just wrote ten great
pages and all they need is just a little
a little sprucing up and they're there
and some days you will write 10 pages
and you will have maybe a quarter of a
pages usable but you will have moved the
story forward that much
and it's it's a kind of alchemy a kind
of a magic of creation but it's such a
beautiful feeling this best job in the
world
oh you're talking about the vomit
draught aren't you all right so we have
such nice expressions for it yes I do
and I urge my students not to look back
that's where the perfection starts to
come in and they stop up their writing
process and these beautiful four four
stacks and then they never go any
further so yes by all means right to the
end and then you can go back in and you
can start honing it and chiseling away
at it or fattening it up make it better
but right to the end barrel forward I
think I think so many people make the
mistake of going back and rereading what
they wrote the day before polishing that
up and only moving this much further we
don't have enough time you know we only
set so much writing time in the day
you've got to make as much use of that
as you can press forward I think that
time frame is is personal it really
depends on where you fit it in your life
you know I've made my whole philosophy
of teaching is writing in ten minute
increments because of being a busy
person myself and knowing that my
writers are busy so I do believe that
whatever time you have you can make the
best use of it as long as you focus and
I make this statistic up depending on
how I'm feeling the room uh I will say
ninety-eight percent of you will fail
and people go oh and I say you'll fail
because you'll never finish you will
never finish your script and and sad but
true I'm not wrong I'm pretty darn close
and I'm pot hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of students at this point and
not finishing is exactly what most
people will do I just have just been
teaching a workshop where I've given
people 12 weeks to finish a draft that
they've been working on for a long time
and the dropout rate is enormous and
this is exactly what you said this is
perfectionism and this isn't not
allowing yourself the ability to fail
and it's a huge mistake
I was the editor-in-chief of my college
newspaper and there's a big sign of the
newspaper office underneath this huge
clock that had a like a blood-red second
hand and the sign said this is a daily
not a weekly and whenever we were there
past midnight the managing editor would
put up another sign that would say don't
get it right did it written and I would
say the same thing to people starting
out writing and people have been writing
all their lives